[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting that's right
dim I'll go with it okay yeah I saw some
of your comments on Soundcloud your
biscuit ears and tweets saying that I
should go with dim lighting and I'm
gonna do it because it's correct no more
arguments no just because the people
have spoken it it doesn't matter I think
we've determined over the years of being
in Trinity nerds it doesn't matter
what's correct it matters what the
comments say okay don't you can we just
live with us follow the comment can we
just live would you say who was joining
us no joining today at the round table
of dim lighting is me and R ourselves
yeah both of us it's another
rhettandlink only your biscuit and i am
excited about this link we're gonna be
talking to ya about the weirdest oh well
homeless mind over your water box sorry
I almost spilled water right in my lap
you're that excited I'm so excited I'm
spilling things the weirdest type was on
it it was the weirdest scientific
experiments ever and the great thing
about this is this is the kind of thing
that we would normally talk about on
good mythical morning right and so I
would say that this is an experiment in
and of itself as an ear biscuit I mean
we try to limit our good mythical
morning episodes to around 12 minutes a
little less a little more that's kind of
how we approach it but there's lots of
times that we just want to keep talking
about something or we find something
that we'd want to talk about on GMM yet
we find that hey we would have to give a
short shrift a short shrift a short
shrift and we're gonna give it a long
shrift whatever shrift is we're gonna
give it that today because we want to
actually explore these things in a more
conversational setting and not have to
hurry through them because any one of
these experiments that we're gonna talk
about this week could be its own look
its own well at least its own episode of
like a Russian scientist creating a
two-headed dog yes yeah things are gonna
get a little weird and interesting on
this be us kids but first we want to
mention our sponsor EF College break
you have College what EF College Break
they make travel easy affordable and
even more fun for anyone 18 to 28
college is not required okay this is
really cool you're young you should
travel and experience global experiences
while skipping around foreign
destinations but the fact is it's
logistically difficult you can spend
hours searching the internet for flights
and hotels and coordinating
transportation between cities with sites
and getting tickets for sites in advance
and dealing with closures and
cancellations and delays that sounds
complicated you could just let each
college breaks travel superheroes do all
that for you
they take care of booking flights places
to stay transportation while you're
there site and event coordination and
provide you with a tour director who's a
local expert it's like you get a Sherpa
for wherever you're gonna travel they
built some places is literally a shirt
actually a Sherpa they've built group
trips across six continents there's only
seven continents people so that's almost
all of them maybe they don't go to
Antarctica yet but everything from
trekking Machu Picchu cruising the Greek
Isles exploring London's pub scene those
are just a few of the trips and almost
half of college break travelers sign up
solo so you won't be alone if you sign
up alone yeah they call it social travel
because you get to meet new people and
make lifelong friends by experiencing
the world together bottom line it
doesn't have to be intimidating to plan
a trip outside of the country the world
is out there waiting to be explored go
for it and then Instagram us pics
so we can experience it vicariously
through you because you're no longer 18
to 28 no we're not I am so jealous of
you so go ahead get started on that
travel bucket list you have no reason
not to because right now and you can get
an extra $100 off your next adventure by
going to EF college break comm slash
rhett and Link I'm on the site now
there's an ultimate Europe trip that's
35 days long Barcelona pari Amsterdam
Rome other cities in between Athens dang
dang is not a European destination
just to clarify languages saying dang
cuz he's impressed with the the euro
trip for $100 off go to EF College
break.com slash ret
Lync we also want to take a second to
remind you about Squarespace because
building a website can be tough even if
you do know your way around coding
creating something that looks good and
works well is a time consuming affair so
whether it's for your business site your
portfolio a restaurant whatever else in
this day and age you probably need a
website and luckily Squarespace makes it
easy to build beautiful websites without
breaking a sweat as opposed to breaking
a website with a beautiful sweat
Squarespace provides simple powerful and
sleek website templates for you to work
with templates that automatically scale
to look great on any device muy
importante every website you build also
comes with a free online store if you
need it just need something minimalistic
but powerful their cover page feature
also allows you to set up a beautiful
one-page online presence in minute
before Squarespace people used to have
to fashion websites out of actual web
they're to gather it from spiders I've
heard that before from you yet like a
few days ago I'm not more I'm not even
more convinced but you seriously you
can't beat the ease and the value
Squarespace gives you 24/7 online
support and beautiful website for only
$8 a month you can even get a free
domain if you by Squarespace for the
year so what are you waiting for start a
free trial with no credit card required
and start building your website today
when you decide to sign up for
Squarespace make sure to use the offer
code rhett and Link to get 10% off your
first purchase and to show your support
for your biscuits and we want to thank
Squarespace for their support of your
biscuits and now let's get back to the
biscuit
will normal people do heinous things
just because an authority figure asked
them to I'm gonna say is this is this
rhetorical question you can answer your
ear rat Oracle yeah but link can answer
it I'm gonna say yes because that would
make an interesting experiment if that
was proven well in a boring experiment
if it wasn't what if you why would you
be talking about what if you were asked
okay to murder an innocent person as
part of an experiment how do you think
you would respond to that this is an
experiment okay no okay I'll go with you
of course not you think that you think
that let we'll come back to this answer
okay this is a I've gone on record as
saying of course not I just want to I
just want to make sure that you heard
that this is a very well-known
experiment you probably if you've been
to college and you took a psychology
class you've probably heard about the
Milgram experiment I was just looking at
the girls man oh I mean I'm a girl when
you're an engineering major girls are in
the psychology right I had like three or
four girls that I would just look at the
whole time I was in a class it was
embarrassing to me
really the more I think about it was
like there's a girl sits over there with
the dark hair there's the girl sits over
there the blonde here there's a girl
that sits behind me I have to turn
around and look at her it's kind of
awkward
well there's psychology involved in that
awkwardness so I mean never talked to
him what was wrong you were learning
some psychology and I'm not sure if we
studied this when I don't remember this
but this study comes from 1961 Yale
University Milgram Stanley Milgram he
told his subjects that they were
participating in an experiment to
determine the effect of punishment on
learning okay
one volunteer who was actually an actor
that he had hired would try to memorize
a series of word pairs so I don't know
if there were rhyming words or whatever
but it's just two words that go together
so the subject whether you have
volunteer or was he an actor he was an
actor acting like a volunteer god but
the subject the person who the
experiment was actually being done upon
who I will call the subject would say
the first word in the ask the
actor for the for the word pair that
goes along with it so so the subject
would test the volunteer exactly it's
like if I was the volunteer the actor
and you were the subject I would try to
memorize dog frog and you would say dog
and I would have to say frog got it I'm
sure it was harder than that now if he
got it wrong the subject would push a
button to shock the actor I'm using
quotes shock the actor because he wasn't
really shocking him it was staged shock
him with 15 volts and then he increased
by 15 volts each time he got it wrong
okay so the guiness begins to add up
quickly if you've ever been shocked so
he would actually the actor would get it
wrong and then he would act like it hurt
exactly and once the shock level got to
a hundred and twenty volts about 120
volts which is pretty serious the actor
would start saying hey this really hurts
he would protest protests in a hundred
and fifty volts he would as expected
again he's acting but you don't know
that as the subject he would start
screaming and demanding to be let out
like let out what I don't want to be in
this experiment anymore I this is crazy
I'm dying here stop this you understand
what I'm saying like was he was he like
in the fourth wall at that point but not
really I mean he's not saying he's an
actor he's just saying I want can't tell
it hurts it hurts too much
was he right there in front of him was
he like in a quarantine booth kind of a
thing I don't have pictures but I'm sure
you can see them online somewhere but
just assume that he's sitting I I
picture him sitting across now at this
point if the subject who's doing the
shocking the person who is doing the
shocking who's being experimented upon
turns around and asks the researcher
who's sitting in the room what to do
like hey the guy singing wants to get
out of here they would always respond
with the experiment requires that you
continue the experiment requires that
you continue okay the results are
absolutely crazy two-thirds of people
the majority continue to press the shock
button all the way to 450 volts which is
the end of the scale which basically
means they would have killed this guy if
this was real oh my god so they maxed
out the knob yeah I mean they do sitting
there screaming you have every
indication that the guy is going to die
but because a researcher who's
apparently in charge has told you to do
this you keep doing it was third what
was the magic incantation to get them to
continue the experiment requires that
you continue that's all you got to say
now listen what do you think about what
Milgram wrote arey this is what Milgram
wrote in conclusion he said okay I would
say on the basis of having observed a
thousand people in the experiment and
having my own intuition shaped and
informed by these experiments that if a
system of death camps were set up in the
United States of the sort we had seen in
Nazi Germany who one would be able to
find sufficient personnel for those
camps in any medium sized American town
this is the phenomena just going it
going to go up to your average normal
person in Lillington North Carolina and
this tone the experiment requires that
you continue you'll kill somebody and
they'll just turn up the heat
mmm that is know so let me that's right
again let me ask you again
would you link it's like that show what
would you do are you in the one third of
people who would not do it are you in
the two thirds of most people who would
protest everyone likes to think that
they're in the one third but that can't
be they can't be in the one third at
least one third of those people are
wrong mmm I don't think that's
statistically valuable no at least one
half of the two-thirds people are wrong
no statistics you're about to say is
anything you're not making up but I get
your point one half of two thirds people
are wrong let's not get into math this
is about psychology odds are you're not
in the one third yes
that's what you're trying to say yeah so
but okay so I okay yeah I would kill
somebody if if you said the experiment
requires that you kill this first I
wouldn't oh you're in the one thing i
i'm i am confident to say that i feel
like or not one you are not a compliant
individual but but you
are you but you put on a lab coat and
I'm yeah yeah but the unfair thing about
it is a lab coats are involved and they
and you have to quantify the power of a
lab coat but be a distrust lab coats
you cannot no person in their right mind
thinks that they're about to kill
somebody I mean they know that it's an
experiment it's not like I mean give me
a break everybody's involved in an
experiment knows I'm not gonna kill
somebody
well until I hurt well I'll take that
back because all it what year did this
happen
uh 1961 okay that's still late enough
that people would know but there's some
experiments later on that are I can't
believe they exist that we're gonna get
to and so if it was much earlier in time
then I think a murder experiment could
have happened and probably has sadly
well but not in the sixty I would say
that people would know it's a
combination of two things people's
willingness to submit to Authority and
the second thing being the slow
ascension you know if it was just okay
you got a president button and this
guy's going to die no it's the fact that
they went up 15 volts at a time it's the
whole frog in the boiling water theory
which is you do it slowly and he doesn't
know if you submit people to if you get
people to do crazy things and it slowly
increases they're more likely to comply
to ridiculous demands if you ease them
into it it's not just say hey kill this
guy it's increase it by fifteen volts I
mean he got through the last fifteen
volts so there's people who are
predisposed to submit to Authority and
those who are predisposed to reject
Authority if we're gonna really simplify
this thing I wonder if that's one-third
two-third yeah I don't know I don't know
math there's got to be more followers
than leaders or there's more you know
yeah I think that'll be a lot of morale
of this one is being the one third guys
don't be - don't be in the two-thirds
begin yeah one-third I'm gonna tell my
kids about that one tonight over dinner
over dinner and I'm gonna I'm gonna hook
them up I'm say put this cathode on your
feet
and you've got cathodes around yeah
I have them under my dinner table every
I conduct a cathode based experiment
with my children after dinner every narc
I call it family to keep them in line
all right I got one here
have you ever grabbed an electric fence
yeah Pete on one two I know I was there
I was looking the other way shouldn't do
that it's poultice yes
oh okay for the record you did not pee
on electric fence and not but I was
there when like I knew what you don't we
would have you yeah I wasn't there for
that but I've grabbed one I've stepped
over one and grazed it accidentally but
you know it's like a ball of electric
current goes through it you three it
makes you feel alive you know and it
pulses that's the thing that's so
amazing about it have you ever seen a
dead guy grab an electric fence no I
don't think that could happen well it
does if there's like a scientist that
makes him do it a scientist was there in
1780 Luigi Galvani an Italian anatomy
professor found out that you could make
the limbs of a dead frog twitch I see
you're talking about frogs I'm gonna
talk about frogs okay make a dead frog
twitch by giving it a shock of
electricity that makes sense and then
scientists all over Europe began to copy
this dude's okay you hear about the guy
doing the frog that sounds like fun
you know it's like it taps into like
what all little boys want to do they
like to shock things for you and see
what burn thing right or
break things but one Italian physicist
Giovanni aldini had bigger plans
he thought what's better than
electrocuting a frog
perhaps a corpse that's right a human
core yeah and this was no secret
experiment either aldini took a tour all
around Europe demonstrating shocking
corpses well this is back
this was 1803 okay yeah this is a good
time for that kind of thing you know
this is back when you could show up at a
State Fair and there'd be a scientist
like shocking a dead body I mean what
happened we use the good old days use
the term scientists very liberally back
there okay his most notable
demonstration happened on January 17th
1803 when he hooked up a 120 volt
battery to the body of an executed
murderer
George Forester they used to do that
kind of thing they would do all kinds of
things with people that wouldn't murder
smart just play with him yeah right yeah
well yeah he murdered people let's let's
put him on a sell a make him a scarecrow
or something yeah learn something or get
some entertainment value yeah
all right first he placed the wires on
his mouth and ears and his jaw muscles
started to quiver and then he aldini he
would start like making and making and
the murderers like he was talking then
trilha quest he day I don't believe for
my crime you're making that part I did
make that part up but he did put it on
his mouth in his ear and his jaw muscles
quivered then his left eye open oh and
looked at the audience it shocked him in
his left eye I'd pay to see that it was
a reverse wink from a dead murder well
yeah I'd buy I paid five tickets at the
fair I that I do a dollar which is the
what used to be the cost of seeing the
world's largest horse okay grand finale
aldini clipped one wire to an ear and
stuck another wire up the rectum well
that's the butt hole right okay
Foresters corpse shook and shuddered all
around the table the London Times
described it thus quote it appeared to
the uninformed part of the bystanders as
if the wretched man was on the eve of
being restored to life like he was
coming back to life right they thought
well when a person moves it's usually a
sign that they're alive or that you're
killing them but if he was already dead
yeah so I mean I think this is less of
an experiment I guess there's stuff to
be learned in 1803 by doing this and
just more of a really cool demonstration
I mean I was taught as a third grader
the difference between a demonstration
and an experiment and the difference is
whether you can charge admission to it
oh really
well this is definitely demonstration
but the interesting thing about it is I
guess at this point they were beginning
to discover from a serious scientific
perspective that muscles are activated
by electricity
yeah so I mean and there were other
researchers who tried electrifying
courses hoping they could bring them
back to
you know that was part of it can we
bring these people bright exactly and
you know if they put today not that I
know okay but these experiments were
inspiration for Mary Shelley's writing a
Frankenstein 16 is when she wrote that
ROM so that's why you know Frankenstein
had the little nodes on the side sides
of his neck and that's where you hooked
him up I haven't read the document the
novel but it's not a document it is a
novel you've seen a movie I'm sure a
novel is a document I've seen very long
doc I have not seen I have not seen the
movie either but I would go and see this
guy if he did that you know they were
you think it's wrong mm-hmm we get the
call do you think that this is well two
things do you think that it's wrong to
experiment with the body civic convicted
criminals mm I would say yes yeah I mean
but do you if you donate your body to
science I mean there's enough people in
it if somebody donates their body to
science do you think at that point no
let's just go all the way let's say that
somebody let's say that I donate my body
to being electrified it fares oh let's
just say I go all the way outside a
thing that says you can do this I'm
happy to see you to have this done to me
make me as look at the audience but Mike
it but it's got to benefit my kids well
I didn't you know you have to get into
the details I'm just saying I I mean I
really like cemeteries but is it wrong
for you then to go and enjoy this is it
is it wrong to enjoy a dead body being
electrocuted and positioned in weird
ways not if they signed a waiver asking
for if it was the part of their wishes
and they were cool with it then I'm cool
with being entertained by it but I don't
want to do it against their wish I don't
want to dishonor them as a person but if
I mean if if it honored them and it
gaint gain some scratch for the kids no
to call it right yeah it's a wise in
college everybody wins okay well then
let's do that
what do you mean whoever dies first will
put the other guy on display as an
electric doll
at state fairs around the water we
really need the Google if we could be
arrested for that there's some states
they want arrest you for that we got to
find those states there's some there's
some counties well that got in some
state that guy does they're waiting for
it
body world or whatever that is thought
about that you know my I mean skinned
art they got the artist I've seen that
stuff man you paid the money cuz they
charge a lot of money I don't wanna
fight armies Weir's I've seen like one
or two displays that are that thing
where it's and what did you learn he's
gross gross I learned gross but if he if
that guy can do that you go one step
further and make them into mobile things
what's wrong with that
like Mobile's hanging from the ceiling
no just like they've become mobile they
start moving with electricity
robots whatever you want to call it I
want to do it if you want in and we got
to get the documentation in place before
the college fund right right yeah
we need another excuse to talk to the
lawyer sir let's go for that give me
another experiment okay I've always
wondered that when somebody gets to get
decapitated do they stay alive and
conscious for a while mmm it's a it's
this is incredibly morbid thought I
understand but especially in a case but
you're being honest this is a safe place
right there there's like a guillotine a
guillotine involved where it's like a
clean cut boom your heads off how long
do you stay alive and conscious well and
if further question is under the right
circumstances if you hooked up to the
right sort of machinery could you just
be ahead indefinitely in life get ahead
in life you know it's like hard like
that well is it there there's like a
cartoon character from some series
that's just ahead there's this has been
done a lot been done a lot I know of
none of it but I'm sure everyone knows
and yep you're right thanks for telling
you well the Russians back in the late
1920s we're also wondering the same very
thing
so Soviet doctor Serge a broken inko
created a machine he
called the Auto jekt er which was
basically a mechanical heart slash lung
and using the auto ejector he was able
to keep the severed head of a dog alive
he didn't go for human he went for dog
because it and you're gonna see as we go
through this that using animals for
these things was much having a lot back
in the day much more accepted than it is
today and and we're not gonna comment on
that what we might in 1928 he brought
his dog head to the third Congress of
physiologist of the USSR these
scientists are exhibitionist and like
back in the day it was like I'm not only
gonna learn something but I'm gonna put
on a show you're thinking about it he's
like I got this dog head I'm gonna take
it to the convention center corner of
course everybody's gonna think I'm
awesome I guess to be fair this this was
a physiologist this was not like a
normal like crowd of oh but he's still
an audience and his experience an
audience of your peers if you're even
cooler I mean he wasn't doing this for
science he was doing this for cool
points oh gosh he shows up with this dog
head now I'm gonna go ahead and tell you
there is a video of this on YouTube I
don't know if it's from this exact
demonstration I think he did this
several times there's a horrible video
do not watch it okay but I know you're
gonna go watch it now and I'm not gonna
tell you how to search for it but I'm
watching it right there's a video of
this on YouTube now it's a dog it's a
white dog's head on a plate with like
some tubes hooked tubes coming out of
the neck of it and he just looks like
he's sleeping like if you zoomed in far
enough but the real question is how do
you zoom out so cool how do you really
impress your friends your scientist
friends well you have to prove that the
dog is alive you gotta make you blink so
he does it the following things he takes
a hammer and he bangs it on the table
next to the head and head flinches what
he shines a large light into the eyes of
the dog and the dog blinks and then yes
listen guys he feeds the dog a piece of
cheese and it comes out the back of the
dog's head because it's just a head
dog like cheese dog heads do apparently
oh man and what are the physiologists
doing I mean they're just like taking
notes
well you Instagram and the crap outta
let me explain something to you we okay
in the Year 2015 I'm gonna pontificate
is that a word yes a little bit
in 2015 we know a whole lot of things
yeah right and it's when we see stuff
like this it's just this is heinous this
is wrong
poor dog this is crazy these people were
nuts but you gotta put yourself in their
shoes right you got to go back to the
1920s when we're not that we're not
still two cuts discovering things but
this was just absolutely fascinating I
mean they are discovering so many things
that it's almost like they forget the
fact that they've sacrificed a dog to do
a cool experiment I'm not saying it's
right I'm just saying that you got to
put yourself truly you got to put
yourself in their shoes for just one
second but what ended up happening with
this severed dog head is it became a
phenomenon in Europe it became a
sensation like they gave it and
everybody was talking about had his own
talk show like hey I'm feeling a piece
of cheese well the dog didn't live for
that long but I didn't live indefinitely
you have a TV special not evil TV was
you know pretty rudimentary back there
but I will say that playwright George
Bernard Shaw you may have heard of him
was quoted as saying about this dog I am
even tempted to have my own head cut off
so that I can continue to dictate plays
and books without being bothered by
illness without having to dress and
undress without having to eat without
having anything else to do other than to
produce masterpieces of Dramatic Art and
literature so he saw this as an
opportunity he wanted to be ahead to
simplify his life and I mean just focus
on one thing I mean come on mr. Shaw
well well okay let me just ask you life
is more than just your your occupation
man your your masterpieces of dramatic
art and literature but you tell me if it
was an option for you as you got old
let's say and
in this world there's a new rule when
you're 90 years old if you've made it to
90 what we do is we cut your head off we
either we either let you just go on and
live and then die normally or you can
get your head cut off and you can be a
head on a plate for the net firt like a
guaranteed 50 more years would you do it
for for 50 more years 50 more years
you'd be a head on a plate cuz I answer
that one cuz then I'm gonna add
something to it so a 90 year old head on
a plate
yeah but nine-year-old hits fine you
don't have to worry about the 90 year
old body decaying anymore I thought you
were going to put me on like a robot
well well yeah I'm going there oh I'm
sorry
what about a plate would you be on a
plate I John lighten your eyes around
conferences everywhere yes yes I'll do
it for the kids again
daddy's daddy's head on a plate well
your kids will be like not for their
entertainment for this light five years
old themselves you doing kids to do
other great great right okay now easy
well you said yes to that I thought
you'd say no I was go see Annie I'll say
no that's gross oh I'm not gonna be a
head on a plate okay
now you get to be attached to a robotic
body an awesome Robocop body no I don't
it doesn't even have to be awesome and
robocopy
okay and what is it like a wall-e like
wall-e yeah it can just look like they
can just be a attach it to the front of
a car hood ornament like but you can
control the cars like a huge Cadillac
but you now can your head controls the
whole car I'd make car noises when I
drove around well you wouldn't have to
do that there's still an engine but that
would be cool right yeah Here I am
and then I could get my head attached to
a car I probably go first because I'm a
little older than you I'm a year older
than you right you'd be even a caddie so
I go first and then a year later you
become a car I'd be on a little smart
car cuz exactly eat anything like like I
could still go to the Opera I'd be on a
scooter then Wow scooter scooter head
ornament there's no hood on us
on top of the handlebars head hood
ornament so but seriously if my head
could be put on a Roma a robotic body at
age 90 that'd be awesome
I'd totally do it I'm totally in
scientists please figure that out oh
yeah you me to give you another
experiment yeah I do this is not gonna
be gross at all and this one has nothing
to do with dogs at all or dog heads
let's go there to the outskirts of
Moscow vladimir demikhov Soviet
scientists had access to some German
ship that all it takes is a Russian
scientist to have access to German
Shepherds around 1954 yeah he said to
himself I know what I'll do I'll take
the head from that dog and attach it to
this dog boom
two-headed dog yes he created a
two-headed dog in a lab a two-headed dog
both heads viable he started with a
full-grown German Shepherd then he took
the head and shoulders and front legs of
a puppy oh gosh German Shepherd and
grafted them onto the neck of the
full-grown German Shepherd and there's
photos of this both heads were alive as
I said and he did this multiple times
now people ask him why and he said that
the dogs were part of a continuing
series of experiments in surgical
techniques so that he could learn how to
perform a human heart and lung
transplant okay good as we know sounds
like an excuse human hearts and human
lungs are totally synonymous with German
Shepherd puppy heads well I will say you
don't know that I mean first of all I
think I think a lot of these things are
motivated by just you know scientists
who are a little bit off their rocker a
little demented but the weird thing that
you definitely have to admit is that
these guys figured stuff out it worked
the and there's stuff to be learned but
let me guess did he parade it around you
asked yes all around the world he took
he took his two-headed dogs
journalists would gas
as both heads simultaneously lapped up
bowls of milk and then they cringe as
the milk from the puppy head dribbled
out of the unconnected stall of his
esophagus oh come oh that's like I
couldn't watch them sorry I mean I just
like the cheese I'm a pretty messed up
dude and I couldn't watch that you know
you watch it with one eye closed you
think so yep mm-hmm
when I close this when I open and then
the other eye would open and both eyes
would be looking at it because I know
you I mean how many times you get to see
see that I can't do it you can't do it
now if we traveled back in time and you
were there you'd look I think with both
eyes the Soviet Union boasted that the
dogs were proof of their nation's
medical preeminence so they made it a
political thing who else has put a puppy
on a dog
ba ba over the next 15 years demikhov
created a total of 20 two-headed dogs
none of them lived too long they succumb
to problems of tissue really there were
problems with you yeah the the longest
one lived like a month and another
surgeon beat him to his goal of learning
how to perform a human heart and lung
transplant Oh because he was probably
trying human hearts and lungs well
that's got its own set of complications
but that was dr. Christian Barnard in
1967 who did that
but demikhov is widely credited with
paving the way for it so I mean right
it's hard for us from this vantage point
especially as you know comedians to not
just poopoo this thing or - ooh ooh this
thing or to judge this thing and but I
don't know well I'm not taking up for it
but I'm just I'm just observing well
you're getting in to make a connection
between the the heart and lung
transplant and the two-headed dog again
again when you're all in the connection
is at the neck by the right and right of
the neck not completely though because
the milk still comes down the back of
the puppy's head right listen the
esophagus stomp I I have a feeling I
have a feeling that 99% of the people
listening to this your biscuit are like
oh this
is horrible and this is the worst thing
ever and clearly it this is a if I had
to explore things that shouldn't be done
in things that I don't want to see I
puppy attached to dog is probably on
that list mm-hmm but it's interesting
when you're on the side of the benefit
of all these things how easy it is to
say but if you've got a if your dad
right now is desperately in need of a
heart transplant or a lung transplant
and the experiment actually is sure come
on somebody it looks seriously
somebody's doing great somebody's dad in
somebody listening to this may be in
need of an organ transplant Ryan would
you say that and this is a moral
question right is this is an ethics
question if we could not have human
organ transplants unless somebody did
weird stuff like this back in 1954 what
would what do you say to that does that
mean that well okay we I wouldn't do it
I don't I don't want my dad to get a
heart transplant I don't want my dad to
get a lung transplant we're really
getting on the hole is it the debate
rages on and I'm not I'm not intimately
not and I'm not today and I'm not
stating on one side of the other I'm
presenting the interesting ethical
dilemma dilemma yes it is one you can't
deny it you can't just say no you can't
do that you can't do that because you
know sometimes people benefit and
there's whole college courses on that
too that I'm sure
pretty girls were in those classes too
like ethics I never took any of those
ethics courses so I'm gonna I'm going to
deflect your question and make a joke
about pretty girls in Mike's college
classes well let's let's continue on
let's see what else
people have done how about this imagine
if you are a bullfighter
okay I'm their eyes are closed I'm
waving the red blanket whatever that
thinks goes 1963 in Cordova Spain hola
and your name is Jose Delgado Tatanka
that's well that's different Native
American but this is Spain
that's Costner there's a bull charging
right at you okay I'm scared I'm peeing
my pants a little and you have a remote
control yeah I carry one with me at all
times and as the bull charges at you
you're seemingly defenseless you're
standing there am i Adam Sandler in that
movie where I can just pause life just
not that no one's seen click click name
of it it's something like that that may
be it he presses a button on his remote
control and the bull immediately stops
Huff's and puffs a little bit and then
walks away seemingly disinterested
docile yes this is an experiment this
happened Jose Delgado from Yale another
guy from Yale they did some weird stuff
at Yale to implanted a chip in a Bulls
brain potato I don't think a potato chip
would have worked this is a microchip
that was controlled by this remote
control well let's here put the potato
chip experiments can we come on we'll do
that okay he called this thing the stem
OC Seaver stim Oh Seaver and it can
manipulate the behavior of the bull it
was a computer chip operated by remote
control that could electrically
stimulate different parts of the bull's
brain and he could he did things like
get it to stop charging but that was
because he was doing a lot of things
including controlling appetite
controlling the emotions of the blows of
a bull yeah all with the remote control
wow I feel bad for the bull but at least
he's got a body
he didn't separate the bull heads he
didn't lay a bull he didn't like full
bull put the bull head on a
remote-control car no he didn't okay
good no emotions and all that yeah so
people are really shocked to hear about
this happening in 1963 this is like a
very seems like a science fiction movie
seems like oh you can't do that even now
but during the 70's and 80's there was a
of research into electrical stimulation
called ESB electrical simulation of the
brain but it began to fade away by the
end of the 80s and most people didn't
like the idea because they thought it
could be used to control people's minds
people's minds and thoughts and so if we
could get computer chips implanted in
people's minds then maybe the government
could tap in and control everybody
button but then he's saying or you could
control your own mind and your own
emotions
well I'm sure people event there are
some interesting questions about this I
mean this ESB research has been on the
rise and there are reports the
scientists researchers are creating
remote-controlled rats pigeons and even
sharks in places around the world but if
you send them like over too many stairs
at once it totally breaks and then like
your four-year-old is like totally
ejected and oh you're like talking like
a Christmas present like instead of a
remote-control car you get a
remote-controlled pigeon yeah and then
you it's like well if it gets too far
away you got a chase after it but it
then then it's not it's not centered so
when you like you press forward it goes
to the left dad why does he keep going
to the left I don't know son well it's a
cheap remote-control bull but the
batteries don't run out that's the worst
part of a remote-control car is like you
get like 10 minutes
you know first of all when you get a
remote-control car at Christmas you open
the thing up and it's like a it's not
charged so all we have to wait 12 hours
before we play with that net by the tits
the next day so today is a Christmas
nobody cares meme dad the Bulls just
stand-in there he's not know anything
well you got to charge him up well no
but the point is you don't ride it out
with a bull linked Bulls don't have
batteries checkmate
it's just a bull so I'm saying the
advantage of having that remote-control
bull right out of the box he's she's in
the front yard he's eating grass he's
running around he's doing whatever you
want but he's having emotions yeah look
I'm making him sad look at how sad the
bull he's hungry no he's sad seems wrong
yeah I will say that I can a bull sad
but what if I could put a computer chip
in your brain
why you gotta be doing stuff to me all
of a sudden and make you like 35 IQ
points higher or if I can I'm 90 years
old and I'm a head on a plate no you
don't have to combine experiment okay
good or what if you know somebody's got
some debilitating brain disease and you
could put a microchip in there and they
can not get Alzheimer's addleson yes
that's a good idea
I'm happy gonna figure that out well we
got to put it in a bowl first right i
I'm just enjoying playing the devil's
advocate here it's interesting it's
interesting but what what did you ride a
remote-control bull I've never ridden
one of those bulls and I'd much prefer
to ride a bull I can control with a
remote than one I'm just gonna like a
bull at the bar like one of those yeah
I've never been on one of those I got a
bad back I I would I'm not gonna get on
a bull unless I can control it it's
emotions right or wrong that's the only
way I'm getting on a bull
like I'm no cowboy yeah I'm note noted
is that all you got to say about the
bull cuz I don't want to cut you off
sure yeah
I moved to the next one we didn't what
do we learn anything about the bull I
mean I learned that it worked
there's no conclusion I don't know what
else he did with the bull all right
here's one for you how far would you go
to prove a theory as a scientist now
yeah did you I mean listen you like to
be right and to your credit you are off
and right oh really I thought you guys
they always know
Stubbins firth a doctor in training
living in Philadelphia during the early
19th century went way too far okay
contrary to popular belief firth who by
the way firth is that's his last name it
has two F's at the beginning yes his
first birth is how I want to say I just
want to go first
for firth hypothesize contrary to
popular belief that yellow fever this is
in the early 1800s was not contagious
because it broke out much more in the
summer than in the winter he theorized
it was caused by an excess of stimulus
such as heat food and noise I mean you
gotta have a theory okay and then you
got it you gotta test your theory yeah
and that was his theory okay I'm not you
know it's 1804 I think this might just
be a case of correlation doesn't always
mean causation he didn't set out to just
test his theory I mean the dude went all
the way to prove his theory he was not
afraid to expose himself to yellow fever
how did he go about that first he made
incisions on his arms and poured fresh
black vomit whoa that is a quote
obtained from a yellow fever patient
into his cuts hold on so when you get
yellow fever you make black gram fresh
black [ __ ] yellow yeah it's all about
yellow fever black vomit
smearing the fresh black vomit in his
why is it black because of the fever I
don't know it should be yellow
sometimes fever is yellow the vomits
black just get over it but other what
I'm thinking is sometimes if you do like
pepto-bismol it makes you poop black is
that a similar effect idea I've never
black vomited you've never had yellow
fever either true he didn't get sick
next he tried some vomit eyedrops oh
gosh which you don't you don't go to the
pharmacy and buy those you have to be a
scientist you have to make those or you
just have to be a guy with fresh black
vomit and an eye drop what what is this
guy he didn't get sick first didn't get
sick he started getting creative at that
point he fried up some on a skillet and
inhaled the fumes cuz everything's
better fried we've established that even
yellow fever did this guy have an
audience that's a good question was this
like one of the I didn't picture people
watching him like drop vomit in his eyes
but I'm sure what in one of those
demonstration kitchens and that bright
up it's frying you know like an
infomercial like a Ron Popeil kitchen
you know look I'm frying up the vomit
black vomit fried it's gotta be fresh
okay look our barb he's inhaling it he
did not get she did not get sick
he got clinical at this point and he
made yellow fever pills and swallowed
those
didn't get sick okay but listen if
you're gonna put it in your eyes put it
in your cuts if you're gonna fry it up
of course if you make pills I don't mom
I don't know you know and he wanted to
be thorough thorough okay I get it
eventually he was like screw it I'm just
gonna drink entire glasses of pure
undiluted black vomit I'm just gonna
dribble so thirsty man it's like how do
you do that
I mean we've eaten a lot of weird things
in our time not that he did not get sick
he rounded out his experiment by
liberally smearing himself with other
yellow fever tainted fluids blood saliva
perspiration and urine where's it
getting this guy left and right and he's
just like hold on sir urine sample what
do you need that for if you're gonna
vomit vomit right here into this I drop
container or right into my mouth or into
my skillet please vomit directly into
the skillet the dudes dudes totally
healthy well maybe maybe he's just got
immunity to the yellow fever he proved
his theory right yellow fever is not
contagious proven by firth actually
yellow fever is very can science fail we
now know that it requires direct
transmission into the bloodstream
usually by a mosquito all that all the
dude had to do was get him a mosquito oh
yeah if I would have told him that oh
you mean to tell me I've been drinking
vomit all this time all I had to do to
dye yellow fever was trying so hard to
die of yellow fever just get a mosquito
out so no some miracle this dude
remained alive I mean with all these
experiments that he's they cuz whoo what
else did this guy do I wouldn't read a
book about Stubbins first I don't I
don't know I'll google him later
IMDB him okay that he's been a star of
stuff oh man early in this guy's
drinking vomit four things I can only
imagine like what is innocent in his
journal and the rest of the stuff that
he did all I really need to do was cut
somebody cut himself and put yellow
fever blood No
no he didn't do that he's made incisions
on his arms in Port vomit yeah but he
made incisions on his arms and poured
blood into those yes non vomit he would
have gotten yellow fever he was here
somebody who's excited on the viand up
black vomit he missed a really good
opportunity to just actually drink some
flecked himself no drinking blood won't
do it either no it won't unless you have
a lot of blood I'll contact yes I did
say that you know you're the one holding
me to the truth of that what would you
drink vomit for like probably three
million views three million views yeah
normal people talk about how much they
get paid we talk about how many views
guys ten million you no no no to dress
shoulder I'm gonna answer honestly now
but I have to think for a second ten
million views we've got videos with 10
million views 100 million views it had
it would have to be you know most viewed
video on earth and I know I know it
wouldn't do it because if it's the most
viewed video on earth it's a video of
you drinking vom I know and that's so
you don't want to be known sad I would
know yeah I'm gonna do that there's it's
like a feedback loop it does it by the
time it gets worth it it doesn't make
sense anymore you know there's no way I
would drink vomit unless it was to like
save the life of someone that I loved
but that's an interesting spirit or
maybe just saved the life of anyone put
the fresh black vomit in a cop parade in
youtubers and then you start promising
views and see who goes for it first I'm
gonna shock this person unless you drink
this vomit no it's purely a view
experiment what would you do for views
Oh sounds like a reality show
makes you feel what would you do water
views can't turn away
we should produce that have nothing else
to do and not be associated put under a
different company with a different name
right like shameful productions.com a
rhett and Link subsidiary
it's tough to say that Wow yeah we came
up with a good idea we move on for the
black vomit we can't our last experiment
comes from a graduate student from the
University of Minnesota in 1924 now this
is a graduate student that apparently
had unprecedented access to the school's
collection of rats
Harney Landis first name was carny carny
yes you know he's up to no good he was
studying psychology and he wondered if
people make the same facial expressions
when exposed to the same stimuli now
you may remember that we did this
experiment or we talked about this
experiment on good mythical morning we
did the thing where they had done an
experiment where they told people to
capture two different emotions together
like happy anger or sad anger or you
know happy surprise and and and we and
then we did that he tried to do it but
then there was like a guy the findings
were that people there was a standard
response of people around the world or a
cross-culturally would you make
approximately the same expressions to
capture the same emotions now this guy
back in 1920 in other words like to
prove that like in another country when
you're really angry with somebody you
don't smile exactly people instinctively
smile when they're happy and they frown
when they're sad and much much more
specific than that
in other words facial expressions are
not cultural at least not exclusively
cultural but this one gets a little crap
this one's weird okay so this is this
graduate student gets his fellow
graduate students to be a subjects then
he paints lines on their faces so he
could see their facial expressions
better where it was he like on the other
end of a football field or something no
I just wanted to be very very precise
okay then he started doing a lot of
weird stuff right in front of them well
he gets him to smell ammonia smelling
something very strong pungent gets him
to look at porn okay he gets them to
reach into a bucket of frogs so a frog
so when we now we already know why all
his friends showed up it's like okay you
get to look at porn and touch frogs okay
I don't if you're in either one of those
oh you knew it for free and they lined
up well but then it gets a little gets
worse okay
finally he brings out a white rat on a
tray and asks them to decapitate it was
it alive and breathing yes a live white
rat from the school's lab oh my goodness
brings it out says decapitate it now if
you remember our first remember our
first experiment link what percentage of
people were willing to murder the guy in
the first experiment seventy-five
percent no sassy six percent exactly
sixty six point six six six six six six
six six six six Oh two-thirds of these
people decapitated the rat when asked
you kidding me what do know two-thirds
he's gonna shock a screaming person who
you don't really believe he's gonna die
it's another thing to murder oh my gosh
you just make that weird noise with your
mouth iced drink some water and then it
like it was the sound of a rat decaf I
was picturing that and he made that
noise it was really unpleasant sorry now
but let me tell you let me tell you hey
let me tell you a little something about
Carney for the other 1/3 he decapitated
the rat for them when they wouldn't do
it he would step in and do it
so three thirds of all rats were
decapitated in this experiment that's
all rats Carney so this sounds like a
car this guy was demented he was missing
some teeth and he was like had his hand
on the lever there let me do it here
give me that rat that gave me five
tickets I'll let you show around a
ferris wheel twice you want to go on the
himalaya he goes forward and backwards
oh maybe give me four more tickets I'll
let you go backwards twice as long so
this guy in it makes me wonder you see
this is it copies here dolfin let me
take a picture your face why are you
doing it let me draw some lines on there
for some lines on your face first let me
be still let me paste your face into the
red you don't want to decapitate the red
that's fine I'll step in here okay but
make sure you look at it from alfred is
just so do you think that will get into
the results of this experiment in a sec
but do you think that people go into
these fields at least back in the day
when you can do all this weird stuff
because they're demented do you think
that people go into science I so they
can decapitate rats I because there are
people who like to do this kind of thing
yeah and I hope cereal because the other
explanation is disturbing that normal
people are just gonna do these things
and be cool with it
right because we want to know that
they're demented because I would venture
to say that even if we were doing this
podcast back in 1924 which is impossible
there were no podcasts back then there
were radio programs listen people
suspend their disbelief the moment they
press play on an air biscuit really yeah
so go with it
okay so we're doing this podcast back in
1924 two-thirds of the listeners would
have done this would have decapitated
rat when their friend Kearney their
friend who they know is named Kearney
asked them to do this he's already
gotten in to look at porn and reach into
a bucket of frogs and then he asked him
to decapitate a rat two-thirds of you
people would do this but I would venture
to say that 99% of you think that you
wouldn't and you said well it's a
different day and age we're not in 1924
anymore but there's something and maybe
that's true but there's something that
is being revealed you know it's it's
probably a lot of things compliance
there's lots of factors here again it's
going back to the first one with the
making people squeal and scream and and
taking the dial up to 11 so to speak was
that where he went with the experiment
no even though this explores the same
phenomenon as the first experiment
people's willingness to obey an
authority he totally missed that and did
not focus on it at all he only
interested in the facial expressions
this was he didn't even think twice
about a he his assumption was everybody
everybody don't chop
of course and if they don't I will step
in now question I got to get to my
answer
I'm not even fascinated with that this
is years before the Milgram experiment
you know he could have been famous for
proving commands compliant but instead
he focused on the facial expressions and
his conclusion was that you could not
match emotions and facial expressions
which is crazy because in more recent
science at least according to the sites
that we use on GMM it has been
determined that these are relatively
consistent across cultures that people
make similar expressions I think maybe
it was just because he was doing really
weird stuff or maybe he drew the lines
in the wrong place
maybe his lines were inconsistent maybe
he's a bad drawer I think the emotions
associated with decapitating a live rat
are pretty complicated maybe it is too
complex I don't I don't want to reduce
that to well you know what I do gross
the the universal there is no Universal
facial expression for gross heinous I'm
not comfortable doing this but I am
doing this like that you know that's
there's what Evelyn's emotions having
what's the expression that you make when
carne takes the rap for you and
decapitate sit I think it's just like
what I'm making an expression that's
like what and I'm never hanging out with
you again Kearney interestingly enough
it's probably very similar to the
expression I make when I get to the
front of the line of the double fear as
well and I'm make eye contact with
Kearney you know good this is not a good
thing I'm not gonna tell anybody this
ever happened to think about the carnies
at the the Los Angeles County Fair is
that they're not they're not they don't
look like normal carnies they look too
clean kyv you know is that been today
the County Fair here which is basically
the same size as North Carolina State
Fair has all the same stuff food rides
animals none of them are being
decapitated or experimented on carnies
aren't what they used a don't have any
missing teeth every carnie that I dealt
with at the Los Angeles County Fair had
full sets of teeth at least in the
in the front region maybe they were
missing some molars but I couldn't see
but back at the North Carolina State for
everybody let me tell you I'm sure it's
still going strong I mean that the
missing tooth is where you hold the
cigarette you know that's what I go in
from the carnies what if we learned
today I think you know as we begin to
wrap up this ear biscuit I feel I've had
a lot of fun learn about these things
our people did a lot of weird stuff and
I'm entertained you know it's what does
that say about you or what does I say
about me because I'm also fascinated and
entertained by this I like to consider
myself as the 1/3 I like to say I
wouldn't kill a person you've proved an
animal I think doing this is Passyunk
was be roasted into two thirds by by
devoting a whole hour to this we may be
in the two-thirds I like to thank my
session are you making listening this
right now you look at yourself in the
mirror who's still listening it's a real
question what you know when we started
talking to mirror the puppy on the other
dog they're gone they were gone if
you're still here look at your face in
the mirror and see what expression
you're making and see if you can see if
you're okay with that I mean I think
that we raised some interesting
questions I would love to there's an
ethics to see your feedback on this
because an Adam I think that these
questions of what is acceptable
exhibition is in terms of
experimentation for the benefit not and
I'm not talking about hey let's test a
shampoo on a rat hey because shampoo
isn't life changing our life shapes a
saving but if it's if it's life saving
for humans is it ethical for there to be
experiments on animals I mean it's
happening everywhere in the world right
now and you are benefiting from it in
every single day that you live if you
just live in modern society so you're
experiencing the benefit of it is it
right or wrong so there's an ethical
question for you to to chew on yeah are
you gonna invite them to hashtag your
biscuits this because are we gonna take
this to the social media forum I don't
know we probably shouldn't we probably
shouldn't get that serious link people
won't know what to do with themselves
why don't we do this we do like the
conversation so comment along on
Soundcloud of course you at the end of
the
so but that's just a reminder you can
comment along if you're listening on
soundcloud or let us know using hashtag
ear biscuits what you think of this
episode or this kind of format in
general you know we're we're still very
much committed to the default interview
installment of your biscuits but we
every month we try to do a Rhett link
only one and this is this is a new type
you know that's GMM expanded director's
cut conversation version so let us know
what you think about that we also
appreciate you leaving an iTunes review
and I'll leave you with one question a
more pointed question not just the sort
of esoteric question of you know what
should we do to animals to benefit
humans more precisely would you
decapitate a rat if you knew that it
would save someone's life somewhere in
the world yes I bet you there people out
there who say no I'm not gonna do that
because if you say yes to that then you
it's it's a difficult question to see
well where does that lead where does it
lead link don't
that was my deflection I'll go and tell
you right now I if Carney gave me a rat
and said if you decapitate this rat
it'll save a person's life I wouldn't
hesitate to do it what if you would to
save two rats lives
that's a good question link right equal
[Music]
[Music]